c'est une deuxième chance qui était
encore inespéré il ya quelques mois dans
cet atelier au nord d'orléans
l'association le lieu multiple permet un
retour à l'emploi à des personnes
longtemps isolé
content je regarde bien où il ya des
dégradations
et je repeins
où il ya des petits dégâts j'avais été
très il ya longtemps les cours enfin le
troisième après j'ai passé deux ans à
élever ma fille est un seul
jet personnes pour le prendre le relais
maintenant qu'elle est grande je peux
enfin pensé à moi ici on fabrique des
caisses de rangement des étagères ou
encore des objets de décoration grâce au
bois collectés dans les déchetteries de
l'agglomération ce travail permet de
salariés une vingtaine de personnes
grâce à des contrats d'insertion qui
peuvent s'étendre jusqu'à 24 mois
ils ont le sentiment de retrouver une
place dans cette société
nous dans les principaux critères de
recrutement c'est le l'envi la volonté
en fait deux de vouloir sortir de ce
chômage de longue durée
avoir une chance et surtout ne pas être
jugé un cadre idéal pour ludovic qui a
passé quelques années en prison ils font
énormément confiance ma tension faut que
leur propre conscience aussi parce que
c'est pas facile il n'a ici quand leur
place puis on a d'autres c'est plus
difficile c'est pour ça que c'est un
monde qu'on apprend à travailler chaque
personne est différente et c'est ça qui
est bien parce que mais lyon n'a amené à
les aider
soutenu par la région et la métropole
l'association a comme objectif d'amener
au moins 80% de ses salariés un emploi
stable après ce premier retour sur le
marché du travail